I definitely think about New Beginnings
but I don't think about resolutions and
the reason that I don't think about
resolutions and the reason that I hope
you guys don't think about resolutions
either is as Mary Shelley said the
beginning is always today and that's the
important thing whenever you're hearing
this video whether it's at the first of
the year or not whatever moment this is
finding you I want you to take this
moment to realize that you can make
whatever change you want to make in your
life as Napoleon Hill said first comes
thought the beginning as you will
observe is in the imagination and that's
the key to getting started is you have
to understand that you already have
everything that you want but you've got
to think about what it is you're trying
to create in your life first you've got
to Define that starting with the goal
and understanding where it is that you
want to go and then Having the courage
to take that first step
you've got to have that courage you've
got to have that willingness to step
forward into the unknown not knowing
where it's going to go not knowing what
you're going to have to do to get there
and not overwhelming Yourself by looking
at the entire task but rather taking a
single step hey it's Evan Carmichael and
I make these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from some of the best and
pick up how you can get up and and grind
enjoy
as Theodore Roosevelt said Far and Away
the best prize that life has to offer is
the chance to work hard
at work worth doing
this is where everybody feels this is
the thing that is the great destroyer of
Dreams people want it to be easy and the
only people that are going to succeed
are the ones that really understand that
the prize that life has to offer is to
really pour yourself into something that
is worthwhile to gain a set of skills
that are going to serve other people to
do something to have a vision
that's bigger than yourself and to go
after it with everything that you have
but ask yourself when was the last time
you poured yourself into doing something
where you gave yourself over completely
and totally to something because that
that's what success is going to demand
of you if you're really going to tap
into the human ability to adapt to grow
to get better to become capable of the
extraordinary to really do something
that is going to change people's lives
whether yours or somebody else you've
got to fall in love
with the process of busting your ass for
something that you believe in and if you
can do that if you can identify that
thing that you're willing to give
yourself over to and take that first
step in Courage without knowledge
without knowing exactly where it's going
to end up but believing in yourself
having faith in yourself
that you can do it
then you'll be able to accomplish
anything you set your mind to and no
matter what day to day is no matter when
this message is reaching you whether
it's the first of the year
or it's a random Tuesday
start now rule number two set big goals
with Grant Cardone I want to share with
you a little tip a strategy that has
never failed me that I wish I'd have
known about earlier in my life I grew up
in a middle class family where the
message was work hard save your money
prepare for an emergency basically that
was the the message right something bad
is going to happen you need your money
save it work hard put your money away uh
save on your deals don't overspend that
whole Dave Ramsey concept about don't
overspend don't get debt prepare for
something bad don't overspend your
situation The Millionaire Next Door all
that that concept you know buy a used
truck
the problem with that while it has some
good information in it the problem with
it it starts limiting and reinforcing
the limits on our lives our potential
and our abilities so here I am today in
my life where I have figured out how to
undo that and Escape
that thinking and that level of living
every day where you're basically worried
constantly about
even when you have a victory you have a
victory I got to save that victory over
here because something bad might happen
and and and it's going to be taken away
from me or my family or I'm not going to
be able to provide for them
that is the basis by the way for what
why you guys invest in houses you you
bought a house because it's a place to
save money you put money away in a Kia
gave it off to Wall Street and the
casino you gave it to them so they could
somehow you know take care of it because
you're not capable of doing it and
you're left in a life at least I was
where I'm worried all the time
constantly worried about what am I
spending what does gasoline cost what
does food cost what's the restaurant
called what's the vacation cost what
does everything cost uh what is what is
a Donora cost so I can't I can't give
her a job she can't help me because I'm
worried about how much money I pay her
so it it keeps people trapped
in their little problems and that's
really what I want to talk to you today
do you have the same problems in your
life today that you had last year
two years ago three years five years are
you having the same recurring problems
over and over again
see the 10x thing the whole 10x thing if
you've heard anything about the 10x
thing it's really about expanding
yourself so you don't have the same
problems over and over I'll give you a
perfect example I grew up in Louisiana
uh I was getting out of college in the
80s
and at that time there was an oil
embargo gasoline went to like three
dollars a gallon the freaking world the
whole world freaked out I think it was
258 275. imagine this the whole world
tripped there was people in lines you
couldn't get fuel
and what happened back then was
everybody started thinking oh my God
fuel cost is going to kill us fuel costs
the cost of a gallon of gas 258 find out
go across town don't spend your gas
literally put more air in your tires
there was news reporters telling you to
put more air in your tires so you would
spend less gas so that got grooved into
my thinking
and my problem and the problem for
Millions hundreds of millions of people
became how much they paid for a gallon
of gas
or how much they paid for food right or
how much that membership cost or how
little they got paid right but in this
case I'm going to use the fuel how much
I paid for fuel determine whether or not
I I would have any extra money left over
and I was trapped in this long after the
all embargo ended by the way 20 years
later I'm still thinking
I remember when gas ran up to five bucks
in La uh just about 10 or 15 years ago
maybe 10 maybe 11 years ago and I was
terrified I'm like oh this is going to
break me it reinforced that idea that I
had long ago now this is this is Years
Years following when I had become fairly
successful five businesses a bunch of
real estate written seven books and I
still had this thing grooving in on me
oh my God man 75 dollars for for a tank
of gas you you you need to start saving
your money again you need to start
protecting yourself you need to work
harder you need to you need to make sure
don't go out to dinner anymore
okay and I got trapped back in my little
problem so here's the game this is how
you play the game I'm going to share
with you a tip here a strategy where I
guarantee you if you do this it will
change the level of problems you have in
your life from little problems to big
problems that's right I said it you
don't want little problems you want big
problems
so let's take the gas okay you see this
right here this is Gulfstream 550.
Gulfstream 550 is 50 50 million 52
million dollars brand new
cost about three million dollars a year
to operate and those wings that Wing
right there takes 25 000 gallons of fuel
25 000 pounds that Wing right there
takes 25 000 pounds pounds not gallons
and what did I just do 52 million
dollars to purchase three million
dollars to operate every year and 50 000
pounds of fuel am I worried about three
dollars a gallon anymore see my new goal
now is I want to buy this jet
I want to keep this jet in the air
I want to go from here to Hawaii in the
jet I want to go from here to France and
the Jet I want to go from here to Moscow
in my jet
am I worried about three dollar gas hey
by the way that Jet's no good without
fuel okay see what I did was and what I
do every day is I simply I wrote my hey
I own a Gulfstream 550 I own a Gulf
Stream 550 I own a Gulf Stream 550. my
attention is no longer on three dollar
gas or five dollar gas or ten dollar gas
it's on pounds it's on Pilots it's on
hangers it's on putting it in the air
it's on inspections and checks it's on
how am I going to pay 50 million dollars
for a jet change your mind okay get your
attention on big giant goals even
unachievable even unachievable these
goals every goal I've had in my life
every goal worth having is unachievable
for you today otherwise it wouldn't be a
goal get your attention on things that
are Out Of Reach okay that you can't
even figure out so that you get your
attention off these little tiny Punk
problems that you've been carrying
around with you for years okay the
concept is this have goals so big so big
your mama won't like this have goals so
big that your problems pale in
comparison all right hope this finds you
well there's another 3 000 videos 3500
videos or so here if you want to
subscribe to the channel do so if you
like this let me know if you have any
comment chance I'd love to help you I'd
like to help you get out of the Trap of
small thinking middle class thinking I'd
love to get you out of the Trap okay my
goal my mission in life is to help
people all around the world get out of
the Trap of thinking too small below
your potential I know you can do more
I've always known I can do more and the
only way to do that is get your
attention off these little problems and
start looking at some things that you
could achieve that would really change
the world you know my goal we just
closed on this Jet by the way to tell
you the fun part of the story we just
closed on this jet
and my goal is to use this piece of
equipment to reach the world to go
around and make friends
around the world not clients to make
friends around the world to to be of
service to people around this planet and
re-educate fill in the gaps between what
your parents gave you what Society has
given you and what the education system
has said are your limits you can do more
than just a job you can you can have
problems bigger than just worried about
gas you could you could literally say
you know what I'm not I'm not going to
just worry about my mama's health
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna somehow
change the hospitals and the medical
conditions in my city my state my
country okay again have gold so big okay
it doesn't have to be a jet by the way
have goals so big that your problems
pale and comparison okay maybe you have
an addiction problem okay you would
change you would change the shift from
your addiction problems your your
addiction to whatever that drug is to
hey I want to resolve the addiction
problem on the planet rule number three
be like a parent with Naveen Jane
there's nothing more powerful than a
changed mind and I'm not talking about
changing your clients mind I'm talking
about changing your own mind because
success is in your mind you decide when
you are happy you decide when you are
unhappy you may think it's your children
it's your client it's someone else who
gives you happiness but imagine if
someone who gives you happiness you're
giving the remote control of your
happiness to them the same people who
make you happy have a power to make you
unhappy happy unhappy happy happy
unhappy right you don't ever want to
give control of your happiness
every one of us here is so focused on
going out and becoming successful that
they forget that after being successful
you still have to go out and become
significant how do you become
significant how do you find the
happiness how do you find the
Fulfillment interestingly the human body
our DNA
is designed for us to be generous
because we realize when we were way back
when in the tribes we realized if we
didn't help each other we all die our
DNA says the only way we survive in the
long term is when we take care of each
other then why is it that we constantly
trying to
play tricks on our mind or play tricks
on our clients mind for them to do
something that they are not intended to
do think about when we hire people what
do we do we take advantage of basic
chemical in our brain called dopamine we
give them a goal if you meet this goal
you get this bonus if you do this you
get a promotion if you do this you get
this it's a constant dopamine hit and
what happens is they get addicted to the
dopamine and they constantly keep doing
it and at the end of the LA and the end
of the day they all feel unfulfilled
because dopamine only lasts for very
little time short time and they all feel
down because you have let them down
the only way you can build relationship
is like thinking of your employees
thinking of your clients
same as your children so I'm going to
say that being an entrepreneur and the
best successful marketing is treating
everyone around you just like you will
treat your children
interesting thing about being a parent
is
there is nothing that you do gives you
the instant result you don't go to your
children and do something and hoping
something will change nothing changes
but guess what happens five years later
Ten Years Later you look and say oh my
God what a wonderful kids they have
grown up to be
and that's what it takes
in fact building that trust and safety
that you do for your children is what
creates the long-term sustainable
relationships
and if you don't do that what you have a
short-term relationship
imagine so what I can tell you is that
as a father one of the things we have
done with our children is amazing we let
them know that our love for them is
unconditional there is never they have
to ever worry about do we love them but
our approval is not
approval they have to earn but they
never have to worry about do we love
them and one thing that I have
absolutely religiously followed there is
never a time when our children will call
that I will not answer this never will
happen so imagine if ever they call you
it doesn't matter what I am doing
there's nothing more important to me
than taking that call I want them to
know that I am willing to give them my
time because that's one thing I don't
have enough of is the time but they have
that that is a true love
in some sense when you're thinking about
as a parent you have to start thinking
about what is it that's important and
what lessons can you possibly give in
part to them that is Meaningful so one
thing that I've learned is the living a
life of significance and teaching our
children about how to grow up in a
family that actually is doing really
well so for me growing growing up in
India was easy we were poor we didn't
have food we could struggle and it came
to this country with five dollars in my
pocket and God has been amazingly kind
to us with that kindness
there was tremendous amount of Burden
that I feel and the burden came because
there were so many people in my life who
helped me become who I am
I tried to find these people try to help
them they didn't need my help
and that was really way for me to figure
out what can I do to pay my dad back and
I realized if I can't pay back I can
certainly pay forward and I was I
decided I'm gonna do what I can to help
as many people as I can
and one of the things I learned was that
fulfillment only comes from something
that is so basic about truly caring
about others
and just like you would take care of
your children
and only story I can tell you what truth
here is my what a story that my mother
told me when I was young remember my
mother was completely illiterate she
cared that even though we were poor she
was illiterate that I study she will
wake me up at five in the morning ask me
read this and tell me what the answer to
this question is in the math
I didn't know that she couldn't read I
will say Mom the answer is seven she
said don't make me look do it again
and I'll do it again say Mom answer is
seven she's good now go to the next one
point was she cared
the story that she told me that I still
touches my heart
she said there was one kid who grew up
and wanted to join a gang and the part
of joining the gang the gang says I
don't think you are quite ready
and I know you already when you can go
in take your mother
cut her off and take the heart out and I
want a beating heart and if you can
bring that we know you're ready to do
what it takes
the young man goes there finds a mother
stops her from breathing cuts her heart
brings the Beating Heart in his own hand
and he's walking back
and he trips over and the heart says son
are you okay
she didn't care what he did what she
cared was is he okay and that's what the
unconditional love is about right so if
you think about it can you truly care
for people or employees in your company
don't think of them as Resources by
calling having a department called human
resources
they are not a resource for you they are
your family so when you tell them you're
joining a family do you really mean it
and if you treat your family that way I
worry about you I really honestly worry
about you that if you treat your family
that way
so one of the things we do always in our
family is that what we do out of love
for our children is not necessarily
right so I can give you some really uh
example that I think we did for our
children that I think has fundamentally
I think you guys can at least get some
wisdom out of it
when our daughter was a 16 year old she
came to me and said dad I found my true
passion I know what I want to do
and I know you love science and
technology I want nothing to do with it
as a father my easiest thing for me to
do would have been thought you know my
doll what is it that you want to do I
will find you the world's best and
pursue your passion
to me that was same as saying I don't
give a [ __ ] just do whatever you want
you know what I did I cared and I said
you know
you have to let me do a job as a father
what's father's job father's job is
really simple let me expose you to
enough things because you have don't
even know what you don't know yet
I and she said well so what is it that
you would like me to do and I say I
would like you to go to Singularity
University learn about Neuroscience
learn about artificial intelligence
learn about nanotechnology and say Dad I
know you don't hear me one word I say
did I just not tell you I have no
interest in science and technology and I
said well if you make me a promise
you're going to go there for four weeks
learn about all these things with an
open mind wanting to learn and wanting
to like I make you a promise that when
you come back you get to do what you
want
she came back the first thing she did
was open the door and said dad I made up
my mind you know what I told her
I sit down
first thing my word honestly was was oh
sh
then I said well I gave you my word tell
me what is it you would like to do she
said Dad I've decided I'm going to be
either a neuroscientist or a geneticist
and I imagine that my I said dull at the
risk of changing your mind would you
tell me what made you change your mind
he said dad you're so dumb you don't
realize that I go to high school I mix
these chemicals I learn these signs and
I say why do I really care
when I went to singular University I
realized you knew I care about girls
education I realized until I learned
about the human brain how can I change
education until I learn about genetics
how can I take care of their health so I
realized science and technology is not a
destination it's simply a tool in my
tool chest to do what I care about
imagine that 16 year old and if I didn't
do what I did the world would have lost
out on a great scientist and she would
have never found her true passion
so at the end what I would tell you
would be
as Peter said
if I ask people what would you die for
is there anything who would tell me what
would you die for in this room I can
tell you most people will say what I
would say are children there is nothing
else in our life we would die for
and if I were to ask you
what are you living for these very few
of them say I live for my children
imagine if there's one thing you could
go out and learn is live for your
children if you're willing to die for
them live for them give them your time
treat your employees like a children
don't think anything when you go out
with you know I go out with my wife and
tell my children don't call me because I
am having my private time guess what
happens when they grow up don't call me
I'm having a private time right if you
don't care about them they won't care
about you so just go out and make sure
that if you're willing to die for them
live for them also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
number four always do one more with Ed
mylett he was saying how some of the
patterns we build we think serve us well
sometimes they're not serving us now one
of your patterns you've always said is a
little extra always doing a little extra
one more like yeah one more like tell us
about who you saw that in or how you
perceived that and how it became a
practice for you in a healthy way so
actually name dropper time but I got a
chance uh when I was a pretty young man
I'm in a gym and Sylvester Stallone was
in the same gym as I was he and I just
the two of us in this very private gym
we both still belong
I've already met him ever won I was a
huge Rocky fan me too I'm a huge brother
and he's and he's got his shirt off
because it's a little private gym that
I'm in and uh it was pretty surreal
experience because in the middle of like
I'm working out with Rocky and we're
doing the rocky workout this is pretty
cool but every single lift we would do
if we had to do eight he convinced me
it's going to do eight and I'd go seven
eight to go one more I'm like one more
and every single rep was one more and I
walked out when we were done thanked him
and we'd become friends since then and I
remember thinking to myself that's a
great metaphor for life if you're gonna
max out your life it's one more and so
it's one more phone call one more I love
you to my children one more reach out to
one of my friends one more uh rep in the
gym so I have this adage in my life
where I just always do one more and
ironically I've linked my
self-confidence to keeping that one
promise because I think self-confidence
is the process of keeping promises you
make to yourself
and that's a promise I can control right
I can make one more text to a friend at
night I can reach I can tell my wife one
more time I love her before we go to
sleep I can walk in one more time and do
my prayers and meditation with my
daughter and that one more in my life
has sort of become part of my identity
and I have this weird thing in my mind
that I think that if I'm willing to do
things most people aren't willing to do
perhaps I can produce results that are
uncommon for most people yes and that's
the one more adage that's why I do I
love that and I think that's such a
beautiful thing anyone who's listening
or watching right now like that is
something you can stop practicing right
now and you're right you know why that's
so perfect is
when you lose someone or something bad
happens you always think of that one
moment that could have been different
that one call that could have gone
differently that one dinner that you
could have had like it's always that
right like when you lose someone that
you love or someone dies or you you
break up with someone you always like
that one like it's always one you never
go oh there were like seven things that
we wish we did right like it's always
like that and so if you're always living
one more then you're already that step
ahead that you're actually stopping
yourself from living with regret I I
I've told you so many times I think
there's so much wisdom from such a young
man with you and one of the things
ironically when you say that that I've
started as a practice to help myself be
present because being present is a
difficult thing in today's age I think
you'd agree for many people it's
projected children are great at being
present but dreaming about the future
still and adults were not so good at
that and it's funny but I do this thing
with the one more where I flip it a
little bit and what if this was the last
one so if it was the last one the last
time I see my dad
how would I treat this engagement would
my phone be done how would we talk what
would I say what would I do what if it
was my last wave I get to Surf out there
in the ocean what if it's my last
workout what if it's my last meeting
last time I saw my wife last time I
talked to my friend last round of golf
last whatever because when something
becomes scarce we give it value and we
become deluded in our life into thinking
that somehow these are going to last
forever I'll always have one more that's
a perverted way of looking at one more
what if it's the last one if we've
learned anything recently with some of
these people that have affected us all
so deeply that have passed away a Kobe
or somebody like that it's because it
occurs to us in that moment that this
could be the last one I S I was with
Kobe
the last Sunday tournament he was at
with his daughter our daughters played
volleyball against each other and I
didn't know Kobe very well not as well
as you did but I observed him that day
and he I remember thinking when he
walked out of that gym what if someone
said call me you have six days left what
if someone would have told him we got in
the car can you imagine in that moment
knowing that this is finite we don't
have forever and so I do utilize that
with myself our conversation what if
this is the last time I get to do your
show I want to make it gives it
importance it gives it value scarcity
means value so I use last ones a lot too
rule number five find your why with Dean
graziosi my life changed forever when I
had a guy named Joe stump Joe thank you
Joe he introduced me to Joe stump we had
this little Mastermind outside my house
I paid him a bunch of money to spend a
day on how to get my students more
engaged and he taught me this thing some
of you my students know this taught me
this seven levels deep to find your why
and I just want to tell you when he
started with me he made me go through
the course with him he made me go
through the seven levels and I'm gonna
go really fast and tell you because I
want you guys to take this away with you
no matter what you think you're here for
on most in most circumstances it's two
or three levels deeper and when you
uncover that it gives you this driving
force that the rest of these uh success
habits have become easy because you know
why and I'm gonna tell you he said to me
why would you pay for me to come here to
help your students and what happens is
when you first get asked and some of you
are more consciously evolved maybe than
I was and and and and then I am right
now but I remember it comes from your
head at first and I remember saying
because I want to create a business
that's strong it's built on a solid
foundation and I want to change more
people's lives and and the whole thing
with the seven levels deep is you ask
why would the previous question seven
times so he said to me well Dean why is
it important for you to change more
lives and help more people and I
remember saying something like I want to
create a legacy and you know there's a
lot of amazing people in our industry
they've changed my life and Brendan is
including Brendan and so many but
there's other people in this business
they shouldn't be in there and I
remember saying I want to create a
legacy and I want people in this
industry to step up or step out I'm
saying all these Noble things coming
from my head and he asked me that seven
times when he got to about the fifth one
I don't remember what else I said but
when I got to the there was three more
questions left and he asked me why all
that garbage went away and it came from
my heart and I got emotional when it
goes from your head to your heart
Everything Changes I get emotional
and I remember saying I don't want to go
backwards I didn't I never said those
words out loud in my life and he said
well what do you mean you want to go
backwards I said well I'm living with my
dad in a bathroom when I was a kid I
wore hand-me-downs I didn't have lunch
money some days my parents always
stressed about money it was always the
main focus in both houses wherever I was
and had lots of houses wherever it was
it was always the focus and I said I
don't want to go back to that I don't
want to go to I don't want to feel that
way so I don't want to go backwards and
then he said well Dean you know I
thought I found my why and he said well
why is that important to you why don't
you want to go backwards and then I got
emotional I mean I can ask Joe when he
said I started crying in front of my
staff there's about 10 of us there I'm
like damn it and my kids came to my
heart and I'm like I just want my kids
to have choices
I didn't I felt so had no choices as a
kid I want them to have choices I don't
want to raise two entitled brats the
world doesn't need any more of that but
I want them to be able to have choices
and I felt I found my why it's my kids
and then Joe said to me he's right in
front of my face he said well Dean I
think you've been working hard before
your kids were born so but there's we
only did six questions there's seven why
is it important for you to give your
kids choices and I found my why and it
just came out of my mouth and I said I
want to be in control
it was just it
I want to be in control I'm not a
control freak what I realized as a kid I
moved 20 times by the time I was 19 when
my parents you know ping-ponging
marriages right step dance Step Brothers
step sisters step grandparents and you
move then we go in a house and we get
evicted and we move I always felt out of
control I go to a school find new
friends finally feel good come home one
day there's a moving truck like here we
go again I never felt in control so what
I realized my why is I don't want
anybody to tell me how to live where to
live how to dress how to talk what to
say this is me I want to be in control
and have no one tell me what to do
because I felt so out of control as a
kid and when I had that why I got it I
immediately know because here's the
thing when you hit a roadblock which you
will when things go wrong which they
will when when everything you think is
lined up and something falls apart to
think you want Financial Freedom or
emotional freedom I think you want to be
a conscious being that's all great stuff
but it's not enough to get you over the
tough days because those tough days
sometimes put us in our old course right
back we get insecure right when we're
were rejected Brendan talked about want
to get rejected when things go wrong
what happens we feel like emotionally we
want to run home even if we're home is
isn't right
but when you know your true purpose on
that deeper level for me when things go
wrong when I think I don't want to go
backwards I want to give my kids choices
and I'm going to be in control nothing
can stop me I'll blow I'll pound my head
through a brick wall if I have to
Financial Security it was good but it's
not that
so spend the time to dig deep whenever
you thought when I said why are you here
think about that and ask yourself why is
that important to me and when you think
you found it ask yourself again why is
that important to me when you feel it
shift from here to here is when you get
goosebumps on your arms and you start
getting emotional and you'll find your
why think about that why write it down
put it on a piece of paper when things
aren't so great look at that it'll drive
you through and rule number six the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is pursue your truest self with Jay
Shetty the challenge today is I'm not
what I think I am I'm not what you think
I am I am what I think you think I am
now just let that blow your mind for a
moment I will explain it I promise I'm
not what I think I am I'm not what you
think I am I am what I think you think I
am which means we live in a perception
of a perception of ourselves so I'll
break it down if I think right
thinks I'm smart I'll say I feel smart
but if I think rangan thinks I'm not
smart then I'll say I'm not smart and so
the challenge is that we're basing how
we feel about ourselves on what we think
someone thinks of us and and the
greatest challenge with that is how do
you have any idea if what you think
someone thinks about you is even true
and whether that's even the best place
to start so that's where our identity
struggles we start pursuing things in
life because we think other people value
them it's almost like let's think of the
most playground version of this if I
remember wearing high-tech shoes from
BHS to the playground right I remember
my mom because my parents didn't buy me
Nike trainers or Adidas trainers which I
always wanted you know we didn't come
from that background I couldn't afford
them and my parents didn't want me to
have them so I'd walk in with my
high-tech trainers from BHS they're
about 10 quid or whatever they were and
and and you know to me it didn't make a
difference I didn't really know at that
time whether high tech was good or bad
they were just trainers that my parents
bought me now everyone the cool kid at
school had the latest Nike trainers all
of a sudden I start thinking that he's
now surrounded by everyone everyone's
talking about his trainers everyone's
giving him adoration everyone's giving
him respect everyone's talking about his
trainers so now I think that if I want
to have that same experience and love
from people that I need to get that
not realizing that I may be able to get
deeper love from people by being kind
and compassionate that I may actually be
able to build a real relationship with
people if I'm loving and and considerate
and empathetic and it's so crazy how
your life can become about pursuing
something and that's why Jim Carrey puts
it best and I'm paraphrasing he says you
know everyone in the world should
achieve everything they've ever wanted
and accomplish everything they've ever
pursued just to realize that it's not
the point now that doesn't mean the monk
mindset is not about not pursuing your
goals
it's actually about pursuing your truest
goals your truest self and your most
authentic aligned goals so it's not
about not having goals it's about making
sure that your goals are actually yours
maybe a year ago or so I saw Gary
vaynerchuk video online when he was
um telling someone at what if his
conference is he was you know he was
talking about BMW and he basically said
to the guy in his in you know in his
inimitable way which is wonderful
um that I think you own a BMW
because of what other people will think
of you when you drive that BMW
and the guy literally you know In that
clip he just sort of sat with it and he
said yeah I do I mean it's what it
symbolized is to to people around him
and again I'm not having to go at anyone
who who might be doing that you know we
all do things
at times to get that
um that validation or what we think is a
validation from people around them but I
think what you're trying to get at is
how do we find our own identity how do
we live our own lives so so Jay how do
we do that have we spent a lifetime
living someone else's life how do we in
our 30s or our 20s or our 40s or our 50s
how do we just decide oh I'm gonna start
finding out what my life is
yes absolutely and and I love the tone
you're sharing this in rangan because my
Tone's the same like you know I'm not
I'm not coming at this from a point of
view of
you know we're wasting our lives or I've
got it figured out like I I don't want
to make this about you not getting your
goals or not having Pursuits or not
wanting to become something because I
want to do all those things too but it's
about why you're doing it and it's also
about making sure they're truly
motivated by your inner desire right
like that's the point it's like if you
want to drive a BMW drive a BMW because
that's the car you love don't drive it
because you think uh if you want to be a
doctor become a doctor because you think
that's how you're going to serve
Humanity not because you think people
will be impressed if you want to go to
Harvard or Princeton or Oxford or
Cambridge go there because you really
want to study how to solve The World's
problems not because you think it looks
good on your resume right that's the
point that we're going after so thank
you wrong for like re-centering that
that tonal piece and I I appreciate it
so where do we start one of my favorite
ways to start
is looking at what we value
and values are a very intangible word
and so there's a very easy way to figure
out what you value there's two things
you have to look at
you look at how you spend your money the
most painful thing you can possibly do
go through your bank statement and look
at where your money is being spent that
is what you value
the other thing that we spend just like
we spend money is how we spend our time
those are the two most perfect ways to
see what you currently value your value
isn't what's in your head isn't what's
in your heart it isn't what's in your
mind it's how you spend your money and
how you spend your time and so just to
give you an overview and I share this in
the book that research was done on how
we spend our time and the research
showed that we spent 33 years in bed
right 33 years of our life in bed and
seven years of that is spent trying to
sleep not even sleeping right we spend
one year and four months exercising
across our whole lives these are by the
way we spend more than three years on
vacation
uh and we spend a bunch of days trying
to get ready and we spend a bunch of
time you know standing in lines and
queues and so much of our time just gets
spent
so the question we have to ask ourselves
is where am I currently spending my time
where do I want to spend it now studies
also show that people everyone has to go
to work so this isn't about what you do
for work people who had more meaningful
purposeful lives and what healthier
wealthier and wise invest their time in
education over entertainment and run in
your your audience is lucky because they
get educational entertainment in one
place but but that's the goal right like
that's the goal that you're creating an
opportunity for people to find education
the the smartest the wealthiest the most
healthiest the wisest people in the
world reading books watching
documentaries taking courses listening
to podcasts learning to better
themselves and so that's the first place
to start the second place when we look
at our value order is I want you to
write down three things that you're
currently pursuing in life it might be a
promotion it might be a new home
whatever it is whatever it is that you
are currently pursuing and then I want
you to ask this question
is that your desire and your dream
or is it coming from something outside
of you is it coming from a pressure of a
family member is it coming from an
expectation because your friend just
bought something where is that desire
truly coming from and the third and
final question you want to ask yourself
is do I still want to pursue that or do
I want to change how I pursue it or do I
not want to pursue it at all and if you
go through that three-step questioning
process you'll get to the truth of what
you truly want to pursue and stop
yourselves from building a sandcastle
which the waves of time will eventually
wash away and so that's what we get lost
doing we get lost building castles that
we don't even want to live in
ultimately I really believe that the
probably the most I don't know the most
sacred thing in our lives that we can
give another human being besides our
love is our labor you think about it
your labor is your energy it's your time
it's your emotion it's your intellect
it's your spirit to some extent and if
you can find a way where what you do for
a living activates that sense of what
you're made for then work is not work
whether you're being Fiji or whether you
be in a an environment that might be
seen less exciting and promising in the
moment trust me I worked in plenty of
those too but with the same level of
excitement and passion because I found
what turns me on that makes me feel
alive makes me feel like I'm doing
something that's worthwhile and on Labor
Day I think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
Labor uh and my hope is to trigger you
to think about how could you turn your
labor into your love I think it was uh
Mark Twain has said when your vocation
becomes your vacation that's when life
becomes truly magnificent and I'm
privileged enough to have that but I
pursued it and one of the secrets that I
found and I know you know this in your
soul is that we all know if you're going
to be masterful at something you don't
show up you know as the best in the
world at something you don't show up in
environments that you want to be in you
get there because you did things for
thousands and thousands of hours most of
you know the concept of Mastery taking
10 000 hours that's an arbitrary number
but I'm sure you've heard about you want
to get really good at something it's ten
thousand hours because when you do
something enough with enough intensity
enough intention to constantly get
better when your labor is your love and
where your labor is something you have
to always get better at then usually
what happens is you get these insights
that allow you to serve more but I also
think that labor you know we're talking
about this weekend what makes people
fulfilled by their labor is is their
motives for it if your motive is just to
make money or just to pay your bills or
or just to get rich or whatever you
think that's going to be those people
never really are fulfilled even if they
make the money the most fulfilled human
beings in my experience and and I've had
the privilege of working with literally
four million people from 125 countries
now around the world the people that are
most alive regardless of the economics
are people that have found something
that they really feel the motive is more
than just themselves you know we all
know what it feels like when you're
trying to do for something for someone
you love and you're not doing it as a
trade you're not trying to get something
back you're just doing it because it's
What You're Made for and I always tell
people motive does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because life supports whatever else
supports life if you're part of life and
you're trying to do something it's going
to make your life better I think the
universe God whatever proper term for
you whatever your belief system is you
know infinite intelligence gets
connected to you and it gives you
insights but I think if you're trying to
serve more than yourself more life than
just you when things support more of
life more of Life shows up to support
you and that might sound kind of Airy
fairy but it's my experience you know
when you're trying to support your
family when suddenly I had four kids
three of them overnight my life changed
my intellect change my abilities changed
because I was trying to serve something
more than just me uh when I started
really focusing how to serve a community
and then a country and then Humanity
with corny as it may sound you get
insights you won't get when you're just
trying to somehow you know make your
labor happen or get the job done so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people I think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at Labor as work they look at as why
should I have to effort so much and in
my experience effort is the reward if
you are doing something you love it's
there so if you don't have it you might
say Tony that's all wonderful you're in
Fiji and you do what you love and I
don't have that thanks so much for
giving me the lecture I'm not coming
from that place I've come from the
places saying you you can discover
something that you're really passionate
about but in order to do it you got to
get out of the story of what you can't
do and you've got to put yourself on the
line it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
uh may be exciting and may release
dopamine the neurochemical that he knows
the reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain
whether it's starting to exercise or
eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
the very nature of how our brain works
is that patterns that have been repeated
over you know months and years are the
dominant patterns in our brain and
therefore it's easier for our brain to
activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness is especially pay close
attention especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results good to be back
today I wanted to talk about um
triggering yourself for success
so one of the biggest things that I
found with entrepreneurs is because we
have nobody to hold us accountable
because it's just us
it's easy to be motivated on fire one
day and then wake up the next day and
like where's that motivation gone so on
my stories I'm doing this new challenge
just woke up challenge where basically
as soon as I wake up I feel myself you
can go watch this morning and I'm I'm
tired and like I turn the lights on and
you know that shock
the point of doing that is that
everybody
wakes up the same way right everybody
wakes up and we're tired and you got
stuff on your eyes and lines on your
face and all that stuff right the
difference is the people who go off and
accomplish their goals and have success
are the ones who then demand Excellence
from themselves on a daily basis right
so the habits your environment your
routine and what I love about triggers
which we want to talk about today and
then and then we'll open it up and get
the Q a is
thinking about things you could do and
set up once but then every morning
reminds you of the life that you want to
live in the game that you want to play
right so if you guys have seen my office
have you seen like the pictures behind
right those black and white pictures in
in the on the office
um
those all remind me to believe more in
myself right this is a store with each
one you may not know some of the people
you probably know who Steve Jobs is you
probably know who Kanye West is and then
the three other people you may not know
but it's AP giannini who's my favorite
entrepreneur who started Bank of America
Howard Schultz who started Starbucks and
then my parents so like me and my
parents were in the middle picture
and the idea with that one is
they taught me that I'm Evan because
really Carmichael I could do anything
that I believe that I can
and so when I walk into my office
they're all staring me down right and
I'm standing basically right with Steve
Jobs next to me and it's it's sometimes
scary I'm looking here and then like
giant Steve Jobs right here down the
side and it's a reminder it's like Steve
Jobs is staring me down it's a reminder
every day that let's go like bigger
bigger no matter how big I think I'm
going there's Steve Jobs right there who
wants to put the dent in the universe
right and so what's great about those is
you don't have to have the same ones but
setting up your environment that you
only think about doing it once and then
every day you walk in and it's that
reminder
so people often will write to me to say
Hey how do I buy those pictures those
posters
well you can't like I'm not selling them
and it's first off it's kind of weird
like it's my parents
you want a picture of me when I'm eight
with my parents on the wall it's like
kind of weird right but what is the
thing for you right designing your
environment so I only have to spend one
day making those and getting them
printed but then I hang them on the wall
and then every day I walk in and it's a
reminder of who I want to be of the game
that I want to play right I call it a
trigger it's a play bigger trigger and
so thinking about what's on the wall
where you're working uh what What's in
all the environments that you work at
um I have a sign on my on my door that
says breathe as a reminder that whenever
I leave the condo I want to I want to do
my Wim Hof breathing so the
right 30 times when we went on vacation
not a vacation we went on our tour
um
I stopped breathing I forgot to remind
myself to breathe because that sign
wasn't on the door anymore and so we
took a sticky note and I wrote breathe
and I put it on my steering wheel in the
car so every time we got in the car we
would Breathe so when Nina and I got in
the car be like okay let's go breathe
right so it's a reminder of the life
that you want to live and the habits
that you want to have that you may not
remember like you may set a goal for
yourself but then you don't follow
through or you don't think is Big
anymore you you have some Vision like I
want to go off and do this and you're
all fired up but then the next day you
play small
and so thinking about first off your
physical environment
what do you want to have that if you saw
it it would make you want to come alive
right so same thing now for you your
business your life when you walk into
your office even if your office is you
know a desk in your bedroom like what is
it going to remind you to play the
bigger game right what's on your I look
at oh my phone's right here look at
what's on your phone right look at
what's on your desktop background
because you look at your phone at least
three times a day right
at least
we'll see you pulling it out like 200
times a day so seeing what's on the back
so my background right now is um we went
to this hotel in New York
and we got this massive upgrade because
the the air condition was out at our
place
so they gave us like the the suite with
the balcony and all this stuff so I took
a picture of me on the balcony working
with like corner and this views of New
York all around and I spent the whole
time working because it's like I want to
work harder to to be here right so it's
a reminder every time I open my phone
so what's on your phone background right
every time you look at your phone what
do you see every time you look at your
desktop what do you see when you get
into your car what do you see is a
reminder to make you want to play a
bigger game
right so play bigger triggers
clothing is also expression right like I
feel like Batman when I put on my my
uniform here right so so even even
putting on something that makes you feel
how you want to be as opposed to how you
actually feel right think about music
that you put on a lot of times you put
on music for how we actually feel as
opposed to how you want to feel
so the first thing that I do every
morning is I put on I have a believe
playlist you can check it out on my
channel
but it's songs that make me move right
you might hate them all awesome put on
songs that make you move
because it music is the fastest way to
change your state
it's the fastest way to go from low
energy to high energy a song that comes
on that would make you start to do this
right that's the right song Those are
the songs that you want to start your
day with so even making like tonight is
a takeaway make a playlist of 20 to 25
songs that if it came on it would force
you to start bobbing your head or
singing along and then tomorrow morning
play one of them and start your day with
it instead of waking up like an accident
right and grabbing for your cell phone I
have a giant bag of Doritos in my office
you guys may have seen it in my videos
the amount of times I get asked like why
is Doritos sponsoring your videos
or Evan you should be promoting a
healthy lifestyle you know stop stop
showcasing Doritos uh I gotta do better
job explaining it but the reason that's
a that's a huge play bigger trigger for
me because all I want to do is eat that
bag every day I love Doritos right
Doritos are my my advice we went to
Costco and we bought the giant one like
the half human size and and that's could
you can only get the original nacho
cheese one on that one so I buy it and I
keep it on the desk because I have a
strategy called Damn the Doritos
so it's a reminder that I'm stronger
than the Doritos I look at that bag and
like all I want to do is eat that thing
right now but I'm stronger than it
and so at the beginning when you're just
learning to get rid of something out of
your life I think it's actually good to
just get it out right when you're on a
diet get rid of all the junk food from
your house
but I think ultimately that becomes a
crutch
because what happens when you go on
vacation and when you go to a party or
go to a wedding you start destroying all
the food that's around you right
and so when you break your leg they give
you a cast and then you you have
crutches but your ultimate goal is to be
able to walk again not to have to use a
crutch forever
right so maybe I'm just a little weird
duck crazy on this one but
I I want to have the Doritos right in
front of me all day long because I think
getting them out of your house is you
telling yourself that you suck
like I can't be around this and so I'm
gonna get rid of it is you telling
yourself that you suck at least that's
how I see it I'm telling myself I suck
that I I'm not strong enough to be
around it
well maybe temporary get rid of it but
ultimately I want to bring it back just
because just to show myself
and people then say well doesn't it take
a lot of willpower to have that Doritos
bag next to you like no like that builds
my willpower gives me strength it gives
me confidence that it's right there and
all I want to do is destroy that entire
bag
right so it comes down to making choices
that make you proud
so there's another one about having your
cell phone don't have your cell phone in
the room
you need to wake up put it in the other
room
so that you have to get out of bed to go
turn it off I hate that
just as a concept like again if you need
as a crutch awesome but but I think
you're teaching every every night you're
teaching yourself you suck
that I'm not going to wake up on time
unless I put it in the other room
that's how I see it at least right so if
that if that was my problem I would I
would want to have the cell phone right
next to me in bed just because and then
turn it off and get up
right like make yourself proud with your
choices there's a very real element to
having like the things that you grow
stronger through ultimately I love being
around
uh negative or toxic people
I love it because
I'm going to suck them into my
gravitational force right we've got a
guy Danny who does most of my filming
and and he had this friend named Hilton
who's from Montreal and he's he's
building up this story about Hilton like
this guy is just
he's always negative and he's always
going to find excuses and reasons why
something won't work you have to work
with him like I'm so excited like bring
in let's go I'm ready and he ends up
coming and he's like this super nice
dude and easy to work with and just
sucked into the vibe but if you bring
your most negative toxic like never
gonna make it bad attitude person and
bring them and they're around me I'm
gonna I'm not gonna get into their world
I'm too strong on my rock I'm going to
suck them in and whoever is more
confident wins I actually like the
challenge
right but you have to have built up a
certain amount of strength to be able to
handle it so I think Step One is
definitely taking out the negative the
toxicity
and then you have this void and what do
you fill it with like what do you feel
it that you look at it every day you set
it up once but it's a trigger for you
every day to go off and want to play
bigger
the most important thing out of a
morning routine is how do you feel at
the end of it
how do you feel at the end of it you
need to feel bold courageous confident
ready to take on the world most people
not you guys most people don't even have
a morning routine most people wake up
like an accident pull out their phone
and start responding to other people's
emergencies instead of you saying no I
need I need some dedicated time for
myself to get into the Zone I need to be
in but even if you've planned out your
own morning routine most people
are just checking the boxes like yep I'm
gonna okay I'm gonna work out I'm gonna
eat this I'm gonna watch a video I'm
gonna read I'm going to meditate I'm
going to pray like whatever your your
list is if you're not feeling bold at
the end of your morning routine you
didn't do it right
your morning routine has to make you
feel bold
courageous
a lot of times it's because you don't
have the right intention going in so
your morning routine might include watch
a video
but if you're watching a video while
making breakfast and brushing your teeth
and making the bed you're distracted
you're not feeling it
you didn't do it right
so think you know what you can add to
your one routine to make you feel more
bold powerful confident alive it doesn't
have to necessarily take you four hours
every morning to do it
but doing that thing if you if you woke
up and did the thing that made you feel
bold powerful confident live for the
next year your life would be
dramatically different when you're from
today compared to where you're at
so as far as like relating it back to
the triggers yeah
yeah what sort of like
sort of strategy do you put to keep
track of if that progress is changing
like how how often will you look back at
let's say last last two months and see
how those triggers are
your new habits and that's a lot more
success for me it's much more about how
do I feel
I want to feel energized every day if
there's multiple days in a row that I'm
not feeling energized then something is
wrong in my environment or my habits or
routine that doesn't serve me anymore
right unless there's some reason right
like if my dog dies I'm going to be
unhappy Nina's not happy I said that
right okay that makes sense but if it's
just a normal day and you're waking up
and and you're not looking forward to
what's happening then then something
went wrong in my in my
my structure so then I'll come up with
something new but if I'm feeling amazing
and I keep going off and doing it so
it's not uh once a quarter I sit down
and block the day off and say okay I'm
going to examine my triggers that can
work for me it's much more how do I feel
so when I'm starting my work I need to
feel like I'm ready to go off and do
something big and bold and if I don't
then
I need to go back and fix
my routine up until that point
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome now it's
time to watch the most eye-opening 60
Minutes of your life check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there so you're watching this and
you've got that business idea that
you've been thinking about forever but
you haven't done it you're watching this
and there's that qualification that
certification that degree you've been
thinking of going after